ho deciso di registrare questo schifo
perché con calma allora il problema è
che ha inventato questo gioco aveva dei
rapporti difficili con la propria
famiglia
nell'ultimo video che avete visto io ho
giocato e sono riuscito a fare bene
molto bene qua no vi spiego sono
arrivata a un punto di questo gioco dove
c'è un boss che tutti su internet
definiscono abbastanza semplice lento
lento soprattutto schiva videro vedova
cosa certa ma bisogna stare bene a
questa quello incassato era così
incazzato perché ha detto mamma
stasera mondo ritorni nella tangenziale
mi porti un panino quello di kata questo
è il boss allora sto cercando di fare
questa merda da stamattina e sono le l
del e colore sono le sette di sera sono
le sette e mezza di sera perché questa
merda
ok questa spada che sull unità solo dove
sa può inviare
è imbattibile va bene cioè è veramente
una così imbattibile perché nella prima
metà a detta di tutti è lento ma non è
neanche così tanto vero ma non è tanto
quello parlava di fisi frisa pure il
televisore potete visione dice ma come
cazzo fai a combattere contro questo
tipo in terra nonostante capo e quelli
su internet per rendere pagine si
iscrivano gli alta la sorella in
putrefazione mara l'inter ma lo sapevo
lo sapevo che è impossibile perché a
voltana egli ebbe prestito non ha
schivato lui però io ho schiacciato il
tasto evidente miglior la prova la prova
il video ho detto lo sapevo prima che
facesse l'attacco quindi lo sapevo non
schivano non lo lancio perché sono
cattivo esempio però bastardo magari
siete sorpresi del fatto che mancava
poco e così da stamattina ha deciso di
registrare perché era una roba atroce e
quindi ho detto a vede registriamo la
gente si fa due risate io no però la
gente lo fa morisse il cugino libro
perché non sia particolari dato
è vano
papà guarda guarda la roba mi sciocca
lotta tutta la vita aveva non so più un
cazzo non c'è tutto avevo accettato come
sono nate le morta scioccata dal super
mario che fastidio madonna che fastidio
sto gioco che fastidio cia che bello
nuovo boss sono ancora battuto vediamo
come
hai visto mai visto lo alzato lo alzate
ho fatto così lo alzato e ho fatto così
ho fatto così ho fatto così l'hai visto
lo alza stato fatto dai [ __ ] i
mari di schivare i giusti appena fa coi
con le dita madonna t'ammazzo non ha
idea di quanti giorni che poi tu non
c'eri c'era che ieri era così e mi
piacciono stamattina porca [ __ ] su
due giorni che sono qua parava mi
colpisce ma schivata perché andrai a
bastia la parte opposta piuttosto ho
attaccato il suo attacco poi no no sono
davanti allo specchio e rami appreso che
stavo rotolando ai box tavolo corto di
cibo e di fuori della gente che scriveva
in crash bandicoot edifici maggiora sta
roba va crash bandicoot e difficile
minchia abituato col monopoly bello io
gioco da solo senza registrare per
rilassarmi notebook acer o un amico
incredibile una schivata che è andata
come doveva da una ovviamente non due
una prova per un tracy scorso ma che
cazzo vuoi non è contribuire in questo
modo ma se mi prende cosa devo fare lui
il locale gesù schivare che permettono
la reed manca la porta quando
scommettiamo che non prendo neanche
danno le ahia ahia ahia più male
l'hack è mai domi chiavi che non prendo
danno il bumber sulla rivale va bene sei
morto già però vediamo come te la cavi
carissimo
temo che di schivare degli stivali colpi
ammazza attivati vorremmo vivere uno ski
michael per mani sindaco ma perché io un
graffietto vedi questo taglio come il
taglio dritto da queste vinto cerna o
animali da lavoro ma le ho recuperato le
anime adesso ne ho tante ormai 30
secondi non di duri che schiacciava
schivata ma non l'ha fatto intendere
figure 7 secondi in due minuti
oggi tu non te ne vai di qua finché non
abbiamo battuto no scherzavo iniqua fino
a domani
2 basta fa schifo a sky cosi subito
buono fin qua che a prima vista
no no ma va il foggia schivando ma che
attacca ma stai scherzando
bravo lascia non attacchiamo fischia ma
basta passiamo da giocare della giornata
schivare i gol tutti all'altra spalla mi
fa
all ideologia occhio occhio e coltivando
già sostituito giorgia schivando è la
prima che ti lazio poi la spada stato
schivando prende con di riformare
politico di spa ma facciamo un elevato
no mai per casinò su giu il corpo di due
me ne vado non è vero non immagina un
basista gioco si si usano le como quindi
fare trattata in anche quello faccio a
giusy e me ne va più di così che cazzo
lo fanno lo tocco neanche ci passiamo il
tempo a schivare molto duro senza
neanche toccare non lo tocco perché
attivo buoni schifo
scrivo spesso schivando senza lo fa lo
fa va bene non falliva schivando vivo
con schivato l'ho anche detto per quindi
perché non lo dovrei fare se stavo per
dire questi alla volta
continua di continuo ad esso finisce sta
roba dovrei andare ad attaccarlo e ma
tanto mi trovo ad attaccarlo ne farà
un'altra un colpo evasa è previso faccio
tutti devi batterlo oppure no
schiva attacca
e attacca uno attacca prof
ok incassi ma schivo e scriva lo scriva
ancora attacca ora vai tu buono
omero duomo
[Musica]
scavate sì no no lavori non verranno
muoio perché non riesco ad andare a
recuperare vita non mi ammazzo prima tu
non ce l'ha fatta è anche una fiala ok
puoi farcela
interrogato chi va
ok free fuori un 40 vita c'è ma io vado
avanti non ce la farò come è bello che
avete avuto di pagamento
così cresce si no gioco di merda
fortissimo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
qualche a [ __ ] degli uccelli in situ di
dio
[Musica]
posso andare a casa quindi grazie gesù
avevano spinto la videocamera perché
tipo sono che ore sono
sono le undici abbiamo spento la
videocamera perché sennò avremmo
registrato dodici ore senza senso quindi
io se non salvo la parte madonna ma
dorico abbas non ci sono più e sta roba
mi ha fatto un punk kraft lonero ragazzi
spero che questo video vi sia piaciuto
torno a casa a tornare a casa loro non
si aggregato qua che non potrà andare mi
pare che mi sia piaciuto ragazzi come mi
piace anche i vari social comitato
descrizione
un grazie a pietro di porto di porto
moralisti ischia temi ci vediamo al
prossimo video beh ragazzi di
[Musica]